elige la ecuación que representa la
hipérbola graficada abajo muy bien
entonces aquí podemos ver cuatro
opciones para la ecuación de la
hipérbola y aquí tenemos justamente la
gráfica de esa hipérbola muy bien
entonces lo primero que tenemos que
hacer es ver que la hipérbola abre hacia
la izquierda y hacia la derecha verdad y
entonces de hecho podemos notar quién es
exactamente el centro verdad el centro
es justamente el origen de nuestro plano
coordenada verdad entonces como como el
centro es el origen entonces tendrá algo
de la forma de este estilo verdad será
algo como x cuadrada / algo que cuadrada
entre algo y esto tiene que ser igual a
1 verdad y esto es justamente porque el
centro de nuestra hipérbola es el origen
verdad ahora además como la hipérbola
abre en la dirección horizontal verdad
entonces el término
la variable x será positivo mientras que
el término correspondiente a la variable
tendrá que ser
muy bien ahora bien también podemos ver
que los vértices de esta hipérbola están
ubicados a 5 unidades de distancia del
centro verdad por ejemplo podemos
movernos 5 unidades hacia la izquierda y
ahí tendremos un vértice podemos
movernos 5 unidades a la derecha y ahí
tenemos un vértice verdad eso quiere
decir que el término en x irá dividido
entre 5 al cuadrado o lo que es lo mismo
es 25
ahora bien tendremos aquí otra constante
verdad que de hecho sería a cuadrada
verdad y este no lo conocemos pero vamos
a ver si con esta información podríamos
ya deducir cuál sería la respuesta ok
entonces analicemos qué pasa con esta
primera opción tendremos x cuadrada / 25
- de cuadrado entre 9 igual a 1 este en
principio es un buen candidato para
seleccionar como respuesta correcta
verdad en principio podría ser este
vamos a ver esta opción aquí tendremos
de cuadrado entre 9
- x cuadrada sobre 25 igual a 1 y este
no puede ser porque el término en que es
positivo lo cual diría que abre hacia
arriba y hacia abajo verdad entonces
esta opción vamos a descartarla veamos
qué ocurre con esta tercera es x
cuadrada entre 9 menos ye cuadrada sobre
25 igual a 1 en este caso aquí
estaríamos dividiendo entre 9 lo cual
significaría que los vértices estarían
en + 3 y en menos 3 sobre este eje
verdad entonces nosotros ya habíamos
visto que estaban en 5 y menos 5 así que
esta opción no es posible tampoco y
finalmente tenemos que cuadrada / 25 - x
cuadrada entre 9 igual a 1 otra vez aquí
tenemos un término positivo en la
variable y lo cual implicaría que abre
en la dirección vertical y eso no es
cierto así que nuestra respuesta
correcta sería la primera verdad de x
cuadrada sobre 25 menos ye cuadrada
sobre 9 ahora bien si nosotros
quisiéramos
entonces necesitaríamos considerar otros
puntos sobre la hipérbola verdad pero
pero en este caso no fue necesario aquí
podemos reducir la respuesta fácilmente